>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Hi there.
Welcome to the Library of
Congress's Digital Collections.
My name is Nicholas Brown
and I work in the Office
of Special Events and Public
Programs here at the library.
It's my great pleasure to
welcome Maestro Leonard Slatkin
to the Interview Studio
here with us today.
Maestro Slatkin is in
town for a performance
with the National Symphony
Orchestra and we're going
to be talking about his most
recent book publication,
"Leading Tones; Reflections
on Music, Musicians,
and the Music Industry."
Welcome Maestro.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Very
nice to be with you Nicholas.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Alright, well it's a treat
to have you back in
Washington since you've been
in Detroit mainly for the
last ten years now about.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: And
could you tell us a bit
about what brought you back to
Washington for this occasion?
>> Leonard Slatkin: Well, I
was the music director here
for twelve years and,
two set of terms,
and after I was getting
near the end of that tenure,
I actually didn't think I would
take on another directorship,
but somehow Detroit
came in to play,
it was a such huge challenge
that I couldn't resist it.
So, between Detroit and then
taking a second orchestra
in Lyon, France, it limited
my time as a guest conductor.
So, somehow dates
never quite worked out.
I think that last time I was
here was even back in 2010,
but now, my Lyon directorship
has come to a conclusion
after six years and Detroit
will end this season after ten,
and I don't want to be a
music director anymore.
I've done it for forty
years; conducted for fifty.
The burdens of endless meetings,
board groups, and auditions,
and all the other stuff that
goes into it, at this point,
it's something I think I
want to put to the side
and focus just on
the music-making.
I want to cutback to
conducting schedule
to maybe 28-30 weeks a year, do
some more writing of both music
and books, and take some time
off just to travel to the places
in the world I would
like to see.
I'm 73 now, so one wants to
enjoy the fruits of the labor.
Anyway, I got asked to come
back to Washington specifically
to do one piece and that
was Bernstein's "Songfest."
We are in what is the start
of a 2-year celebration
of Leonard Bernstein; he would
have been a 100 this coming
August, I'm not quite sure why
they're all starting this early,
but they are.
And "Songfest" was one of
two pieces that he wrote
that were premiered by the
National Symphony Orchestra.
We're also playing the other one
which is a short
overture called "Slava!"
dedicated to my predecessor
his music director,
Mistislav Rostropovich.
So, when we decided and
found the date that worked,
now I just have to fill
out the program and I want
to do another work that,
at least I associated
with Bernstein, but that had
perhaps more popular appeal
to the audience, and that's Igor
Stravinsky's "Rite of Spring."
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Excellent.
I think we'll come back to
"Songfest" a little bit later
in the interview, but "The Rite
of Spring" pops up in your book
in quite a interesting way
in the story of an experience
with a Mexican orchestra.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Sorry
to jump [brief laughing].
>> Leonard Slatkin: Well,
first you have to understand
that the book is a kind of
mixed bag book where I'll move
from one subject to the other
with not much rhyme or reason,
but in my head there was.
I like to think that if
I'm in a conversation
with someone that's sort of
the way I would be talking.
I can't go into all of
it otherwise we'd be here
for six hours, but
essentially what happened was,
very early in my career,
I was asked to guest conduct
an orchestra in Mexico City
who at the time were
paying me an outlandish sum
of money to come and conduct.
I didn't understand why,
but I decided to do it,
but the condition was that
I do "The Rite of Spring."
I had no idea about the quality
of the orchestra, but I thought,
"Uh, okay I'll go to it."
And, I knew on day one there
was going to be a problem.
The rehearsals weren't
in an auditorium.
They were actually in
an abandoned garage.
So, there was this
orchestra there and we start
and right away there's a
problem, because the piece calls
for two bass clarinets, but
only one of them is there
and I looked and I said, "Where
is the second bass clarinet?"
And I'm told that he was
at the dentist or something
and he would be back for the
afternoon rehearsal; fine.
The rehearsal was a real slog.
When you get that point,
even at a first rehearsal,
you have to make decisions about
what are you willing to let go
and what are you going to work
on that's going to make it work?
In the afternoon of the second
rehearsal, we start again
and now there's still
just one bass clarinetist,
but it's a different person
than the one who was there
in the morning, and
I said, "Excuse me.
So, I needed a second
bass clarinet."
And they said, "Yes, I'm
the second bass clarinet."
I said, "Yes, but
your colleague,
the first one, where is he?"
He says, "No you just
said you needed the second
bass clarinet."
"No! I didn't mean that.
I meant I needed both
of you together."
And, I didn't see the
two of them together
until the last rehearsal.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Well.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Well,
so the whole rehearsal
schedule goes like that.
It just insane, and finally
we get to the concert
and I really wasn't sure
if we were going to be able
to play the piece
through without a stop
or a major problem.
Got through the first
part close enough,
second part I was going along
and I'm realizing this
is going to be okay.
I'm going to get through this.
And then, in the last section,
the "Sacrificial Dance",
very complicated
technically both for conductor
and for the orchestra,
from offstage we start
hearing a voice [singing].
It's getting closer, and
closer and on the stage,
walks basically a construction
worker with high hats
or hard hat and overalls,
and he's singing away.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And
three violinists put
down their instrument,
they tackle him,
the drag him offstage,
but I'm determined.
I'm going to finish the piece.
I do not want to have to go
back and go through this again.
So, we finished it and
it ends, I'm not going
to say indecisively, but
just with a like that,
and nothing from the
audience, absolutely dead
and it take the baton
and I just drop it
onto the podium hoping
it will make a noise
and people will figure
out that it's over.
They finally started applauding,
but in my dressing room,
these journalists all comeback
"What did you think of that?
Was that disruptive
or whatever?"
Being from Los Angeles,
I can have a very
sarcastic sense of humor.
Not that you can't have
it from any place else,
but I had this sort of way
to make something seem real
when it's not, and I seemingly
looked to them and I said,
"You know, I had read that
Stravinsky somewhere had thought
about incorporating
operatic elements
into this ritual sacrifice to
the pagan gods of Russia and now
that I've heard a voice
associated with this music,
I think I'm going to investigate
this further" and sure enough,
next couple of days, the
reviews are all talking about
"Rarely heard Stravinsky
music now possible"
and all this kind of stuff.
There were a lot of
other stories connected
with that whole trip.
And when you read
the whole thing,
it's like no this
is not possible.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: But, I
did have it corroborated,
I was in a kind of a shop, not
a hardware store, but something
like that, and there
were two people,
this is about three years ago,
they come up and they said
"You probably don't
remember us."
I said, "No."
Said, "We played in that
orchestra in Mexico City"
and we went through the
whole thing and sure enough,
everything I remembered
is exactly what happened.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
That's wild.
>> Leonard Slatkin: So,
there are moments in our life
that when they're
occurring seem disruptive,
but and in retrospect,
you go, you know,
this is really funny enough.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
To want to tell.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Neat, very cool.
So, that's one of the things
I enjoyed about your book
so much was that you let the
reader into you as a person
and what you're experiencing
throughout your career whether
it's in the business side,
which has its ups and downs
or the music-making side
or the family side as well.
Would you mind sharing
with us a bit
about your family background.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Sure.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: In music
and then also how that's
impacted you personally
and professionally
and then also you son?
>> Leonard Slatkin: True.
Well, four-and-a-half years ago,
I published my first book
never really thinking
that it would have
much impact at all.
I've always written
ever since high school;
I used to write short
stories and since 2008,
when the web became interesting,
I would write a monthly column,
I would write articles for
newspapers, for magazines,
and finally people said "You
know you have such stories
to tell and your family
history is so interesting,
why don't you put
them in a book?"
So, the first book
which was called
"Conducting Business" was kind
of an autobiography memoir,
but primarily meant to
inform the lay public.
The music lovers
not the musicians
about what a conductor
does; how do we study,
how do we decide the
end of the profession,
what it's like to be a
music director working
in the Opera House,
recording, being on tour,
health, all those things.
And it's sold very well
much to my surprise.
And people started
saying, "Well,
is there going to be a sequel?"
And I said, "I don't
really know."
And then I started looking
at all the notes I'd made
and realizing how much I
left out of the first one,
but I wanted to take the second
book in a different direction.
So, rather than considering
it as a sequel,
it's more like a
growth and continuation
of what was in the first book.
Essentially, my family
were Russian
in origin from my grandparents.
My mother's family settled
in the states in 1903 prior
to the first revolution
and my father's family
settled in St. Louis in 1912.
On my mother's side,
everybody was musicians,
every one of them
all mostly cellists.
One of them, one of my mother's,
my grandfather's brothers
was named Modest Altschuler
and when he arrived in New York,
he founded something called the
Russian Symphony of New York
which is all Russian
immigrants, and they would play
for fourteen years
a series of concerts
at Carnegie Hall giving American
premiers of a great deal
of Russian rapporteur, but
also some unusual things along
the way.
My mother, along
with her father,
were outstanding cellists.
Eventually, the Aller side,
actually the Altschuler,
that was the real name;
there was this rift
in the family we have
like two opposite sides,
they wound up moving
to California.
My father' side, this
group having come
from the Ukraine,
settled in St. Louis.
My grandfather on that
side was a barber.
There were no musicians
other than my dad
who could be heard practicing
apparently by everybody.
When I arrived in St.
Louis as the assistant,
you would swear everybody
lived on this little street,
Washington Boulevard, because
they all talked about being able
to hear my father play.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: I didn't
know his sound was that big.
Eventually, he also would
relocate with his family
to Los Angeles and there was a
competition held before young
soloists; the award
would be a performance
in the Hollywood Bowl
with pianist conductor
who was Jose Iturbi
and my dad won.
My mother was furious.
They had not met.
She felt the whole
competition was rigged.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Uh-oh.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And she
went back and she started
to give my father hell about it,
she said, "You didn't deserve
to win, that I should
have been the winner."
Well, somehow they thought they
should continue the argument
over coffee and a bite to eat
and two years later
they got married.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Funny.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
So, with that in mind,
they moved in three different
directions of the music industry
in L.A. First, my dad
was concert master
of the orchestra at
20th Century Fox.
There were eleven
studio orchestras each
with their own actors,
writers, directors, producers,
and musicians and composers.
So, he was at Fox, my
mom was the first cellist
over at Warner's and
she was the first women
to hold a titled
position in the studios,
and this is the late 30s.
In the 40s, they formed one-half
of what would become a very
famous group mostly known
on recordings because
they didn't tour a lot;
they were called the
Hollywood String Quartet.
They couldn't tour a lot because
the studio work kept them very,
very busy.
And the third part of the music
resistance [phonetic] was the
part of the popular
music industry
and the recording field,
particularly for Capitol Records
where people like Nat King Cole,
June Christy, Stan Kenton all
of the people who were
recording for the same one,
but in particular,
it was Frank Sinatra
who became very close
to the family.
My brother and I,
when we were young,
referred to him as Uncle Frank.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: When we
were little, he would take us
by the hands, lead us upstairs,
put us in our beds
and sing us to sleep.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, my gosh.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yeah.
We spent a lot of time with him
in his homes in Palm Springs
and Las Vegas and he couldn't
have been nicer to the family.
Obviously, if you were a friend
of Sinatra's you couldn't
have ask for a better friend;
if you were an enemy, you
couldn't ask for a worst enemy.
So, I grew up in this family
where there were not
boundaries in music.
We didn't think about classical
music as up here and rock
and roll was down here.
If it was good, it was good
no matter what the genre,
and I've stayed that
way to this day.
I do a lot of things that
many conductors don't do,
simply because they didn't
have that as children.
Having this kind of background
was in some ways a big benefit,
but a slight curse because
if you were associated
with doing lighter music,
some people say "Well,
okay he's not that serious."
And I knew that was a risk,
but I couldn't be without it.
Jazz became a hugely
important part of my life,
first as a piano player and
as a conductor and a listener,
and that hasn't changed either.
So, I've enjoyed this existence
of just experiencing all kinds
of music and it is due to
the influence of the family
and all the people we met,
because all of those folks
that I mentioned and
virtually every luminary,
whether it was Stravinsky, or
Hindament, or William Walton,
or Sinatra, or Korngold,
Tiomkin.
Max Steiner all the big
film composers right
through to John Williams,
Jerry Goldsmith and so forth
and so on, all of them
were at our house.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And
they all played on the piano
that I still have and to
us they were just people.
They were normal.
I didn't hold anybody in the
highest esteem in the world,
I held baseball players up
there, but not musicians.
They were just really good
people to get to know.
The other thing that
did have an impact
on me a little bit later
had to do with 1955 and 56
when the McCarthy
hearings were taking place.
The film studios were
among the prime targets.
Generally, people who are
in the arts, the performers,
the painters, writers tend
to be a little more
liberal in their thinking.
The people who are donors,
however, surprisingly tend
to be a little more
conservative.
So you have to find that
balance, but McCarthy went
after musicians and almost
anybody he could involved
with Hollywood including Aaron
Copland who, one was accused
of being a communist,
a homosexual, Jewish,
which he denied in Congress
but then later it turned
out he was all three
and it caused complete
chaos in the film industry.
All the studios then abandoned
their separate setups.
They're making one pool
actors and musicians
and directors for
all the studios.
Actually, he wound up putting
people out of work rather
than the theory that it
would open up everything.
So, all of a sudden I became
interested, not quite yet,
but later on in the history
of the unions, vis-à-vis how
and orchestra is dealt
with, because they're part
of the negotiating process.
But these days with the,
in many cases, very,
very healthy salaries that
orchestras are making,
I think the union's
job is not be involved
with orchestras except
for pensions,
health benefits,
things like that.
Unions are good I think
for the studio musician,
bursting the club date, things
like that take care of them.
So, a lot of things from
the past have come back
to me recently and
so I wanted to talk
about some of them in the book.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Yeah, great.
And now your son is in music?
>> Leonard Slatkin: He is.
Now this is unusual because
I didn't have the best luck
when it came to being married.
I had two early marriages,
neither of them lasted
more than two years.
Just, but those separations
were all very amicable,
it just didn't work.,
but in the third one
after I think nine
years, Daniel came along
and now there was a
different reason to focus,
but as many musicians will
tell you, it is very difficult
with this life on the road so
much and focusing on career
and the hours you need
to study and work,
it's not something you
leave at the office.
You bring it home
when you're home.
So, I was away a lot.
I fell to temptation
a couple of times.
My wife and I became really
antagonistic, our son saw it
and eventually we separated
and I worried about my son,
because I didn't know
what was going to happen.
He had been interested in music,
but only on the peripheral.
He played piano, played viola,
but we were all convinced
he wasn't going to go
into the performance end at all.
When he went to private school
during his high school years,
he started playing guitar; did a
little bit of drumming I think,
and then out of nowhere
he decided he wanted to be
in what's called the
"music industry" meaning go
to the University of
Southern California and study
to be possibly a
producer, an engineer,
maybe have a management
of a bunch
of rock groups stuff like that.
Three-and-a-half years into
that program, out of nowhere,
came "You know, I think
I want to compose."
And I went, "What?"
He says, "Yeah, I don't want to
deal with the nonsense that goes
with the management
side of the profession."
And very quickly, I mean really
quickly, he acquired the skills
as a composer and so
now at age twenty-three,
now going to the UCLA Extension
Division, he's writing music
for films and television,
he's wrapping
up his first documentary, he
has a couple of short films
out there, and I'm not saying
this as a proud father,
this is very distant, he's
really good at what he does
and I think he will be
able to make a good,
strong name for himself
after a while.
He's very serious.
He has a fiancé.
They probably won't get
married for a couple of years,
but they're very supportive
of each other and he
and I have become
very close now.
In fact, as we are
talking, he's here on this.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yes.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Trip to Washington.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yes, yes.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And he
came to rehearsal yesterday
and all the members of the
orchestra who knew him,
you know, when he was yea
high, they just were so happy
to see him again and it was;
especially his first piano
teacher was playing keyboard
in the orchestra.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, that's so great.
>> Leonard Slatkin: They
had a great reunion.
So, it's a different
kind of pride.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: You know?
Of course, I realize I better
not mess up with the concerts,
because if my son gives me
a bad time, it's all over.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
Excellent.
So, your son, you mentioned
that he studied piano.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yeah.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: And was
that his primary
instrument always
or did he play [multiple
speakers]?
>> Leonard Slatkin:
He played viola.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Uh-huh, interesting.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And he
actually was the only violist
in his middle school or
actually that was still here
and a rather cute story
evolved from that.
He was playing viola
in the string ensemble,
but he was a pretty
good pianist.
But there was another
kid in his school
who was top class
pianist, very young,
just one of those protégés
who could do anything.
And Daniel in his last year
in school here, really wanted
to play something on the
Spring Concert on the piano,
but he was worried that the
other kid was going to get it,
because superior talent.
And when he told me this, I said
"So, you want me to basically go
to your music teacher and
say would you please let
Daniel play?"
And I said, "That may
not be the nicest thing,
but let me try something else."
So, one night I sat down and I
started writing an arrangement
for piano and strings.
I guess it was a Christmas
Concert, that's what it was
of a couple Christmas songs
that could be played
by that age group.
And I went the music
teacher and I said,
"I know you probably have
Ben" the other child playing,
"but maybe you might
be interested in this
because it's age appropriate
for your young string players
and it would feature Daniel
on piano and would conduct."
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Dun-dun-dun.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
And, I guess it's a form
of bribery I suppose,
but that's what we did
and that started a
small part of my career
that I never thought
would happen.
I went on to write twelve pieces
that began the collection,
and then I wrote another twelve
and now a third volume has come
up with single line instruments
and it's all because of
that little genius Ben.
He probably has no
idea what he started
and these actually sell very
well among more than schools,
churches; churches
really enjoy doing them.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Interesting.
>> Leonard Slatkin: It
was just another fun.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Cool.
>> Leonard Slatkin: To do.
I like adventures
outside of the conducting.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Has Ben
stayed in the music industry?
>> Leonard Slatkin:
I don't think so.
I think he, I know he graduated
from whatever incredible
college he went to.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: You know,
but early he was just
one of those kids.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Interesting.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Right.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Neat.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Probably
be a serial killer now.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Oh, gosh.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Probably.
No.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Hard part.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Yeah, hard part, yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Where did you live in D.C.
or in the area when you were?
>> Leonard Slatkin: We lived
almost entirely in Potomac.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Okay.
>> Leonard Slatkin: In Maryland.
And I used to love
driving down to the center,
because I could either take the
canal road down and cut over,
or I could go over to the
junior parkway and I could get
from my garage at home
to my parking spot
at the Kennedy Center;
one, no billboards;
two, not one stoplight.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: That
will never happen again.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: No.
Not at all and now they're
doing constructive over there
and all that kind of stuff.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yeah, but I
loved that drive in the morning.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
What have you seen
change in D.C.
since you've started coming here
and since you living here and.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Oh, absolutely nothing.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Oh, yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Gee, it's all the same.
You know, I was hanging
out the Clintons and.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: A
little bit with the Bush's
and you know here this trip I've
been waiting for my invitation
to the White House,
but I suspect that's not
going to be forthcoming.
But, those, in those
administrations,
often the Presidents and
First Ladies would come
to the concerts.
Members of the Diplomatic
Corp. lots of people
from news divisions
became very good friends.
I think that the Kennedy Center
itself, which has so much
to offer, still remains
a little bit disconnected
from Washington life,
in the sense,
that when you're a tourist
say you come, yes you want
to go the Capitol, you want
to go to the White House,
you want to go to
the Smithsonian,
come here to the Library
of Congress, whatever,
and it's not the first thought
to go to the Kennedy Center.
I still think no one's quite
solved yet how do you make
that structure and what's
inside, an integral part
of the city, maybe
because of where it is.
I know they're extending
it out now trying
to build a pedestrian mall.
They tried that quite a while
ago even while I was here,
and the costs were
too prohibitive.
So, maybe the physical way
it connects will help a bit,
and I'm hoping that Deborah
Rutter will really use her
incredible skills to
help make that happen,
but it's made it a
little more complicated.
People don't really know
that your government,
your taxes do not go
to the institutions
within the Kennedy Center.
They go to the building.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Maintaining it,
because it's a national
monument and making sure
that the upkeep is there,
but the institution
still rely primarily
on philanthropy and
ticket sales.
So, when you talk about
ticket sales, you're talking
about potentially high prices
and that shuts out a lot
of people and the
ability to come,
even though on bus
tour you're going
to see three million people
looking at the Kennedy bus
and the Hall of Flags and all
that, but they don't really go
into what it's supposed
to be about
and that's making the arts a
living and breathing thing.
So, I member one of the things I
did right away, I went on a tour
like the first day I got here.
I got a tour but they didn't
know who I was and it shocked me
that we really never
went into a hall,
none of the performance spaces.
So, I immediately
opened up the rehearsals,
I said "If we're rehearsing,
you bring that tour group,
they stand at the back
behind the railing,
and stay for five minutes."
They said, "Well, don't you
think that will be disruptive?"
I said, "No.
They'll be so in awe and
surprised and pleased
to be there they
will be just fine."
And I suspect they still do it.
I don't know.
My back is always, I mean,
I never see what's
going on back there.
But I always thought that was
a good start for opening it up.
But, they're going to have to
reconsider pricing structure.
I know they're doing a lot
of good work now in Outreach
at least in the orchestra,
having Mason Bates
as the Kennedy Center
composer residence is great,
because Mason is just terrific
at understanding so many levels
of the artistic experience,
but it really is a question
of making it come together.
If you look at the other
major venue in the country,
Lincoln Center, and
it's sitting there right
in the middle of everything.
You can't miss Lincoln Center.
And when you look at the
Kennedy Center it just,
it's not quite connected
to anything physically.
So, they're going to have
to find other ways
to make that work.
So, that remains what it was.
I do see a lot of new
independent stores opening
up as I've been driving
around a little bit
and that's very pleasing,
certainly the restaurant
scene is even better
than when I was here.
There's just so many
wonderful places to eat.
Obviously, one notices the
heightened security sadly,
and as we're talking it's
not really tourist season,
so the city is not too crowded,
it doesn't feel like it anyway.
So, at the moment, it
feels like the people
who are actually residents
of the Capitol are
the heart of the city.
They always have been, but
when all the tourists come,
that changes the
dynamic of the city,
it changes who it
is and what it is.
The administrations are
going to come and go,
that's always going to be.
There will be a whole new core
of people every two, four,
six years and you
took that in stride.
It made it difficult
in some places
to establish some
long-term friendships
with people I wish I had
gotten to know better,
just because they're here
and then they're gone
and it's hard to find them.
But, essentially there's
still an excitement
to the city knowing
that we're in the place
that when everybody turns
on the national news
and sees what's going
on, here in Washington,
you turn on the local news
and the local news here is the
national news everywhere else.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
That's very interesting.
One of the things in our
collection is we have a lot
of Bernstein's papers of
course, and Aaron Copland's
and many other major,
major figures
from the 20th Century
American History and culture.
And in Bernstein's
correspondence, particularly
with the Kennedy family, you
can see when he first interacts
with Jackie Kennedy when
J.F.K, was in the senate
and they had some correspondence
then and then as it goes forward
and their relationship
into the inauguration,
and we have this Frank Sinatra
telegram that Frank sent
to Bernstein talking about
he called him a genius
and saying how he'll
see him at the dinner
and there was a whole story
with a snow storm and then
into the White House time how
the, how Bernstein was pulled
in to certain things to
advise on a personal level
about the arts and arts
policy and then was brought
in for certain state functions
where the diplomats from Japan,
for example, and
then the whole period
from after J.F.K. was
assassinated and the letters
that Jackie wrote to him on
the night of R.F.K's funeral
which is just mind-blowing.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
I could imagine.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
At four in the morning,
it's ten page thing
just pouring her heart
out about Muller it's amazing.
And then how they were
so connected later on
and with the Kennedy
Center, of course.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: With
Mass and with "Songfest."
What is the appropriate balance
in your mind or a civic figure,
or culture figure like yourself
and the civic society
whether it's the politicians,
the you know, the Chamber
of Commerce, etcetera?
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Bernstein was unique.
I mean, never before had
there been a musician
who infused himself into
virtually all aspects
of society the way
Bernstein did.
But then again, Bernstein
was the very first American
conductor to have achieved
an international reputation.
He was intellectually curious
all the time and loved,
absolutely adored being
part of the interaction
with every figure, but I'll get
back; I have one quick story
about the Kennedy Inauguration.
So, Sinatra is invited to sing.
Sinatra said, he's coming but
there's a condition, my mother
and dad had to be the
respective first cellist
and concert master
of the orchestra.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: So, I have
photos of them with Bernstein.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, my gosh.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
At the inauguration
and do you know what the
gift was that everybody got?
>> Nicholas A. Brown: They
got one of those books?
>> Leonard Slatkin: No.
They got a cigarette holder.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, really?
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, my gosh.
>> Leonard Slatkin: You know,
a thing like that a
silver the thing on it.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, that's pretty cool.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
That, you know,
that was very generational.
Anyway, so we can
say today that a few
of our musical figures have
tried to interject themselves
into the political scene anyway,
certainly Daniel
Barenboim's done it.
Dudamel has kind of waffled,
but sort of getting drawn
in a little, and my predecessor,
Rostropovich clearly wanted
the same kind of thing.
But Bernstein was the one
who could pull it off.
And you only have
to go back and read
that fantastic lengthy essay
in the New Yorker written
by Tom Wolfe where we got
the term "radical sheep"
which describes the dinner
party at Bernstein's apartment
when he invited the
Black Panthers over.
That was Bernstein.
Trying to understand and
somehow put diverse groups
of people together.
He truly believed
that he could do this.
I think it was an
interesting time.
I don't think it was
necessarily meaningful,
but for me personally, I
try to let the music more
or less speak for itself.
What we have to do as a
performing arts institution,
I'm going to cough and
I might need the water.
One second.
I can pick this up.
>> Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Thank you.
[ Background Sounds ]
If it's down here
you won't see it?
>> No, yeah that's fine.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Okay.
What I think we need to do
as performing institutions
or artistic institutions is
to make what we do available
to as many people as possible,
mostly through an
education system,
because since I was a
young person and now,
arts education especially
in the public schools
has just deteriorated.
When I arrived in Detroit, the
supervisor of schools bragged
that 30% of Detroit
schools had music education
and I just looked at him
and I said, "And 70% don't."
So, I've been working the last
couple of years to find a way
to fold arts education, not just
music, but painting, sculpture,
architecture everything,
into the history curriculum.
No piece of great art
exists in this vacuum.
We always have something to
say about the society in which
that artist lived whether
they're looking ahead
or looking back or
providing commentary.
So, maybe that helps if history
teachers get a little bit
of education as well
into interjecting the
arts as they go across.
Then we'll see.
Maybe there will be an outcry
from some public people
to have that, but we're
two generations now
where it's been declining
and declining and declining.
But with that being said, we're
seeing an influx in our country
of something quite
different than what we saw
when I was young and what
my parent's generation saw.
Our artistic heritage in almost
every way came from Europe
or Russia or one of
the Slavic countries.
Today, the influx is coming
from Asia whether it's
Japan, Korea, China.
These are the people who
understand that becoming part
of the global marketplace means
that you have to become part
of the western cultural
scene as well,
and they are producing
outstanding talents
in every field.
So, our job, I think, as artists
are to encourage this diversity,
embrace the new Americans.
Obviously, I'm as the
grandson of immigrants,
not so keen on how
we keep people out,
because maybe you're
going to prevent something
from happening, but
you're also maybe going
to lose out on opportunities.
So, perhaps the system under
which we let people in needs
to be looked at very
carefully, but there's a lot
in this world none of us are
ever going to be able to change.
All we can do is identify
those who we see have promise,
who have talent, the
dreamers, all these people
who will make American
life better as we go along.
The focus now is on the
people who will make it worse.
I tend to want to
think the other way.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
You've been in Detroit
at such a pivotal time in the
city's existence and it sort
of moving towards a new
potential, where was the city
when you found it as a music
director and where is it now
as you're preparing to
complete your tenure?
>> Leonard Slatkin: I hadn't
planned on going anywhere
after I finished in Washington.
I thought that was it
and then I was asked
to guest conduct the Detroit
incredible Hall, just really one
of the great halls of the world,
not so big, about 1800 people.
The orchestra was good.
I really didn't even
know they were looking
for a music director, but
somehow we hit it off.
Board members came to me,
we hastefully arranged
a couple more concerts
to see if it would work.
But along the way,
people were saying, "Well,
you know there's going to be
a lot of problems in Detroit."
We already knew that the
economic downturn was happening
in Detroit two years before
it happened everywhere else,
so 2006 is when the automobile
industry was really on the verge
of a kind of collapse, 2008
for the rest of the country.
What that meant, that perhaps
the upswing could take place a
littler earlier if there
was going to be one.
And then, into the
third year of my tenure,
the orchestra was on strike.
They were on strike
for six months.
And everybody had told me
that was what was going
to happen before I took the job.
Everybody knew this.
And that's when I took
it on as a challenge.
I said, "I've got to be here.
I've got to be part of what will
happen when the strike is over."
So, during the work stoppage,
I was meeting with musicians,
board members, management,
talking to the other people,
"What do we do the
day the strike ends?"
And we started putting
in initiatives.
We webcast for free
all over the world,
every subscription concert
now are educational concerts,
as well as, others.
We offer incredible pricing
structures for young people;
for 25 dollars students can
buy what we call a soundcard.
We're not one of those
cities where people walk
up at the last minute
and buy a ticket.
We're; the suburbs
are too far away.
So, we know two weeks in advance
roughly what our ticket sales
will be like.
And we're not talking about
just orchestra concerts,
anything that's done
in Orchestra Hall,
you pay the 25 dollars,
you're in,
but it's 25 dollars
for the whole year.
It means after one, certainly
after two events everything
after that is free.
You get the pricing
structure right, you're going
to attract the young people.
The third thing we did
was to go out and play
in those suburban communities
increasing subscribership
by about 3500.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And
adding almost six more weeks
of classical concerts
for the orchestra,
more and more orchestras now
are relying on pops concerts
and playing musical films and
those are all fine, again,
if it's good it's good.
But I know the musicians
appreciate getting their teeth
more into the rapporteur or
they're older or contemporary.
So, those things
that we did helped
to spur other organizations, not
just arts ones, but businesses
to say "Hey, the orchestra
has just really gotten ahead
of the curve here", and all of
a sudden, new people were moving
into Detroit, the largest
community of artists for example
in Detroit is coming from where?
Brooklyn. It's too
expensive in Brooklyn.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yep.
>> Leonard Slatkin: So, they
come, they buy these properties
that are inexpensive, redo them,
and are creating sensational,
really interesting
new works of art.
I don't recognize
much of the city
that I came to nine years ago.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: No.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Which at the time,
looked like Berlin in 1945.
Yes, there are still large
pockets that remain burned down
or empty and whatever,
but gradually you see
the transformation that's
taking place.
There's still a long way to
go for both the orchestra
and for Detroit itself,
but one good number is
that when I started
out of the orchestra
at that time I think
was 92 players.
Only one lived in what we
would call the "downtown" area.
Everybody else lived
in the suburbs.
Over the last year, I hired
seven new players and out
of the seven, six of
them live downtown now.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And
that's a big change.
The shops were moving.
The restaurant scene
has become terrific.
The art museum, another thing
that was potentially
going to disappear.
The city itself voted,
because it's a city museum,
if you pay taxes, the
museum stays in business
and the residents in
Detroit City voted
that they would not allow
the museum to fall victim.
Amazing. So, it's
been a great story.
I had to change my set of goals.
I had a slightly different
artistic agenda when I started,
but now my job was just to help
get the orchestra, not just back
on its footing, but really
in a more prominent position
than it had been and
through all the initiatives
with all the people that
helped, I think we've come
to a very good place and when
that happens then you
say, "It's time to stop."
Let somebody else take
over and build from that.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Are
there any specific repertoire
programmatic decisions
that you've made in Detroit
to maybe tap into
the young audience
or to grow that subscriber base?
>> Leonard Slatkin: Well,
you don't really want to be
in Detroit in February.
If somebody said, "Where
are you going in February?"
"I'm taking a vacation
to Detroit."
"No, you're not going
to do that."
I'm from L.A.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: I
mean, I don't know what all
that stuff is that's
falling from the sky
and it's causing my car
to stall and slip out,
but a lot of our patrons, the
ones who are the big givers
and all that, they leave for
the slopes or for the sun.
So, one of the first things
I did was start a series
of festivals in the
February period,
they're three weeks long.
The first year it was all
the Beethoven symphonies
and three weeks.
Then the next one is all
the Tchaikovsky symphonies
and all the concertos
in three weeks.
Then it was all the orchestra
works of Brahms' and then
after that it was just
a whole pile of Mozart
and this year it's
a French Festival.
These go on for three weeks,
two different programs each
week, each played twice.
Very low-cost, but also tied
into the subscription scheme.
So, subscribers who are there
can go, but if you want to come
to one of these festivals, you
can get a really great discount
on being able to come in.
And I guess the best
statistic I could cite is
that when I started nine
years ago, ticket sales were
at about 61-62% at
house on an average,
and now they're going
closer to 93%.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And it's
due to all these factors.
It was complicated
but also simple.
A lot of it was just saying,
"What does this community need
to make it interesting?
What would it take to get
people to really want to come
to the Detroit Symphony?"
For young people, it's
not the repertoire
and it's really not the artist
unless it's a big pop star
or something like that,
it's the pricing structure.
Can I actually get into
the symphony for less money
than it's going to cost them
to go the movies and spend all
that money at the concessions?
>> Nicholas A. Brown: One of the
interesting discussions you get
into in the book, is applauding
between movements and you seem
to have a an attitude
about it that I like
and that I'm in-line with, but
every time I have that kind
of conversation with
certain colleagues
or certain musician
friends, you know,
there's a whole negative
chastising thing
that goes on and.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Would you
mine sort of summarizing that?
>> Leonard Slatkin:
It's pretty simple.
Really it wasn't until the
20th Century when this concept
of not applauding
between movements started.
We don't quite know
how or why it did.
It might have even been more
an intellectual movement rather
than an emotional one.
Beethoven's 7th Symphony at
the premier slowly was played,
the audience applauds widely,
and they repeat the slow
movement before going
on with the rest
of the symphony.
And this was the
case all the time.
And a little bit like if you
went to a pop singer's concert
and they do a song, and they're
going to segue into another one,
but people will applaud and
you have to either wait to go
to the next song
or whatever it is.
With symphonic music,
it's pretty clear
when a composer might actually
have encouraged the applause
especially in the concerto;
first one usually ends
in a flourish and
whether it's Tchaikovsky
or Paganini whatever
it happens to be.
I find that the applause
is a release
of tension for the audience.
They've been sitting
like this for 20 minutes,
and now yeah, [clapping] okay.
It's probably inappropriate
say at a string quartet
which is an intimate surrounding
or even at a recital maybe,
but for an orchestra concert
there's just some pieces
that beg a response.
Where I think the naysayers
argument falls flat,
has to do with the same practice
being acceptable in an opera.
So, in Tosca the soprano
finished Vissi d'arte
and the audience
cheers and screams,
goes on for a
minute-minute-and-a-half,
but not only is the
musical flow interrupted,
the story stops dead.
So, why is that okay?
But at a symphony where
usually the composer,
unless they have said they want
you to go from this movement
to the next what we call
a attacca, right away.
Why can't they applaud?
Why not? Certainly, I can
name no musician that I know
who doesn't want applause.
We all want it.
It's a question of when.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: I think
it has to be done though
out of the emotion
that's generated.
So, it doesn't bother me at all.
I don't encourage it.
I know it's; I don't finish
something, give it cutoff and go
to the audience, you know, okay.
I won't do that, but if somehow
there's a feeling of wanting
to express themselves, that
should be, and on the other side
of that coin, one
thing that's missing,
at least in concert
audiences, you still see it
in Italian opera houses, there
used to be all these complaints
about new music, less so now,
because the new music is
a little more palatable
to audiences, composers are
more diverse, but if you don't
like it, why aren't
you booing us?
Why aren't you letting us
know how you feel about it?
Audiences feel uncomfortable
expressing displeasure,
but they shouldn't.
How are we going to
know unless you tell us?
I do get letters every so often.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: But,
it's not the same thing
as a good lusty boo.
But once in a while, you will
get a response that's unexpected
from the audience and usually in
music; I remember being on tour
with the National Symphony.
We were in Florida.
We were playing Charles
Ives' "Three Places
in New England" the second one
ends in this cacophony of sound,
it just ridiculously distant
and it's just kind of ends.
And we heard from the back
of the hall, "Oh my god."
And then, a few weeks
ago in Detroit
when we opened our season,
we were doing Beethoven 3
of all things, and after
the first movement,
we didn't finish, you don't
usually expect applause there,
and they didn't,
but we heard "Wow."
But better than that, was at
the very end just as we finish
that last chord and right
before the audience started,
somebody goes.
"Hell yeah!"
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Oh, that's awesome.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And, you
know, we all we loved it.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
That's great.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
We thought, you know,
okay you know they're really
showing us how they felt
about it.
So, I really don't have a
problem with this at all.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Yeah, cool.
Someone who was new to
our concert audience here,
this was like three
or four year ago,
it was probably a string
quartet concert or something
or a new music concert, and
this person was a young person,
twenty-something,
very well dressed,
clearly very intelligent, and
they were just loving everything
and they were clapping
like it was a pop concert
and not everyone appreciated
it, but I was like "Come on,
this is their opportunity
to experience the art
in the way that they believe."
>> Leonard Slatkin: But, why not
breakdown one of the barriers?
And one of the barriers
is the communication.
It's not just we are
playing for the audience
and there's this thing up
there, the invisible wall.
No. We want to know
how the audience feels.
We react to that.
We play. You can
sense from the stage.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Even
with my back to them,
I know if the audience
is with us.
You feel it.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Do you read frequently?
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yes.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: What kind
of books are you reading now
or do you prefer to read?
>> Leonard Slatkin:
I'm wrapping up;
I used to have a
couple books either
on the electronic reader or,
because that's for traveling,
otherwise they kind of
charge a little too much
for the extra weight.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Or
at home, so I'm finishing
up the recent biography
of Toscanini
which is really interesting
by Joe Horowitz I think
wrote this, I think.
And I'm rereading
James Baldwin's
"Go Tell It on the Mountain."
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Oh.
>> Leonard Slatkin: I find
sometimes when I see something
in our culture, I find myself
being thrown back to the 1960s
where much of what we're
experiencing today is
reoccurring, but to be frankly
in a much more horrifying
manner.
So, I go back and I read works
that were influential to me
as a young person to see if they
still resonate and, in fact,
they do resonate usually more
than ever, more than ever.
And I think now having seen
the Ken Burns Civil War series,
I will probably now go back
and look at that differently
and read, I'm not sure which
book yet, but that came
because this year I'm doing,
I'm conducting a score
to Buster Keaton's silent film
"The General" usually recognized
as one of the top ten or fifteen
films ever made in this country
and I had it scheduled for
two places, and I got flack
for saying well, this is about
the South in the Civil War,
and I said, "No it's not.
It just happens to be then."
Keaton's character is conflicted
because he runs this train
as the engineer and he's a
very good engineer and his,
the person he loves wants
him to be a solider,
but the Confederates don't
want him to be their soldier
because he's such
a good engineer.
There are no slaves in it.
There's no Robert E. Lee in it.
Yes, there's a battle
and the South wins.
Guess what?
The South did win some battles,
but one organization decided
they would go through with it
and they'll do it, but there
will a panel discussion
and the other one said no
it's just too hot a topic.
And, I find that sad.
I find that erasing
an important part
of our history as
conveyed via art.
It's incomprehensible
to me, but that happens.
It, I do understand why in
Israel they don't play Wagner.
I understand that and that will
probably change at some point,
but this is a different
thing altogether.
This is something where
you want young people
to understand the
creation of our country.
How we evolved and maybe how
we've gotten to the point
where we are today, devolved.
So, I was glad I won one of
the two battles anyhow, So,
yeah I do different things.
I read. I go to movies a
lot, product of Hollywood.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yes.
>> Leonard Slatkin: No choice.
And I go to sports events.
I got back in time to
watch the last five innings
of the World Series last night.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Are you a Dodgers fans?
>> Leonard Slatkin: Sort of.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Oh, geez.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
I'm a Cardinal fan.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
And I'm a tiger fan.
You know, I didn't really
care, but I just I wanted
to see Verlander
go against Kershaw.
I'm just sorry that
didn't happen.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: I
really wanted to see that.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: So.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Maybe next year.
>> Leonard Slatkin: No.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: No?
>> Leonard Slatkin: No,
the Cardinals/Tigers
series next year.
It's got to be.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Very good.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
It's not a prediction.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Oh, okay.
Since we've just now
gotten into some topics
about American society
how it evolves and such,
I'd love to go back
to "Songfest."
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yeah.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: "Songfest"
is, of course, this collection
of songs that Bernstein composed
setting various different
American poets from different
periods, different backgrounds,
comings, Whitman,
Gertrude Stein, etcetera
and with my experience
of studying the piece
is just it's bold
in the statements it makes.
It's not necessarily making
positive statements at all
for most it, but it feels
like it stands apart from some
of Bernstein's depictions of
American culture and society
in that it's more maybe
realism and less optimism
in some ways, I don't know.
>> Leonard Slatkin: I agree, but
I put it a different context,
I'll give you five works in
Bernstein's concert output
which is what he wanted
and hoped he would
eventually be remembered for.
He was really tired
of being identified
as the composer of
"Westside Story."
We should all be so lucky to
have written "Westside Story."
But, you start with his
first symphony "Jeremiah",
dedicated to his father and
not exactly the subject matter,
but the nature of his
Jewish upbringing is infused
within this work.
Now you come to the second
symphony, "Age of Anxiety",
an Auden Eclogue all
about alienation.
Three people trying to figure
out who they are what
their role is and all that.
It's not necessary to listen to
this piece with that in mind,
but this is very
descriptive of Bernstein
as his conducting career is
developing, he hasn't written
"Westside Story" yet, but he's
written Broadway shows and it's
like he's searching for what
is his real place going to be,
he doesn't quite know yet.
Now, you come to
"Kaddish" which is 1963,
written just before
Kennedy is assassinated
but not performed until after.
The Kaddish is the Jewish prayer
for the dead where the word
"death" is not mentioned, but
the word "life" is three times.
And there's a narration
in this piece which begins
to express the conflict
between man and god
or whatever you do
or don't believe.
The first performances
were narrated by his wife,
one a women is not
allowed to recite a Kaddish
in the traditional
Jewish [inaudible],
and the text was
roundly criticized.
It was also Bernstein
trying to deal
with the prevailing
musical thought of the time
which was 12-tone serial
music which he does for some
of the piece and then abandons
and we hear him a little more.
But it really is about
that struggle of faith
which would then continue
into mass where now it's;
sometimes things are we've
got to hear Bernstein's mass.
It's just the word "mass."
It's not mass and b
minor, it's not a mass.
It is not specific
to any religion.
It is, again, about that
struggle between somebody
who should be pious in some
way and not knowing how to deal
with it, but it was very
much a piece of the 60s.
There was a rock group in it
and all this kind of stuff.
In some ways, to me it's
not holy successful work,
it's just a little bit too
dedicated to the times,
but it very much
continues now Bernstein
between the Kaddishness
realizing that he's bisexual
and he doesn't know how
to come to grips with it.
That's where his
crisis of faith is.
And finally we come
to "Songfest."
And you pointed it
out, but I'm going
to give you a slightly
different spin on it.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Yes, definitely.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Of all the
pieces that Bernstein wrote,
this is the one that is the most
autobiographical of Bernstein.
You might have been going there
anyway, because almost all
of the poems deal with
some aspect of his life.
So, if you're talking about
"The Pennycandystore",
that's Bernstein's childhood,
but doesn't it kind
of 1940s style jazz.
Then you come to Julia de Burgos
the only song not in English,
and this is about a
fight for women's rights
and for the possibility
to break shackles.
Then you come to the Whitman
poem, the only poem we know
that came later were written
and is acknowledging his
homosexuality and one
of the most moving songs
ever written, ever.
And there's Bernstein again,
and you go through it
then you get the duet
with Langston Hughes
and the other name.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
June Jordan.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Yeah.
First of all the juxta positions
of the two poems is amazing how
it works, but now you're talking
about the Black Panthers
over at Bernstein's apartment
and one song after
another tells you
that this is an autobiography
of Bernstein seen
through these other poet's eyes.
So, I treat these five pieces
as being in a way better
than reading any
biography of the composer,
because they tell you what
he stood for in his life
through his music and the use
of the words that he chose.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
June Jordan actually
recorded the poem.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Oh, really?
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Right there.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Wow.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
It was pretty wild
and we have it up
on our website.
>> Leonard Slatkin: You don't
have the Langston Hughes
one though?
>> Nicholas A. Brown: No,
I don't know if we have.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
Wouldn't that be cool
to put them [brief
laughter] together?
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Yes, in the same realm.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And it's,
"Songfest" has an
unusual history,
because it was not
premiered as a totality.
The first performance was
of, I don't remember how many
of his songs, but
maybe six, seven,
and it was for a
July 4th concert.
Now, July 4th here in
Washington, you know,
flags are out and people are
going out and they want to hear
"Stars and Stripes"
and they want to hear
"1812" and all these things.
Well, all of a sudden
came this piece with texts
that were angry, texts that were
touchy subjects people did not
want to deal with.
And I believe [inaudible] was
then not allowed to play 4th
of July for a couple of years,
and the administrations now were
very careful about what could
and could not be done
on this occasion.
I'm sure they thought
Bernstein was just going
to write us a good old patriotic
piece and we'd get the preview
of "1600 Pennsylvania Avenue."
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yeah.
>> Leonard Slatkin: But,
that wasn't to happen.
So, finally he put it altogether
and the piece was premiered
here; he recorded it,
but I also have another
piece to start the program.
Very rarely played,
he wrote an overture
for Rostropovich's very first
season it's called "Slava."
It's great fun.
It's really almost like
"Candide" on steroids.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yes.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
And Slava conducted it.
In it, there's a portion
where the orchestra used to,
they don't do anymore, you're
supposed to yell out "Pooks"
which is the name of Slava's dog
who came around all the time,
but at the end the
orchestra does to go Slava!
for Rostropovich and
then comes the end,
but those are the two pieces
that the orchestra played
that Bernstein wrote for them
and I thought they would be nice
and they're coupled with
"Sacre du printemps"
for the simple reason
I grew up with his,
Bernstein's first
recording of it.
The first time I met him it was
the piece he was rehearsing.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Oh, wow.
>> Leonard Slatkin:
And I thought if I had
to pick a non-Bernstein piece
other than Mahler, to associate
with Bernstein it's
the "Rite of Spring."
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Excellent.
To wrap up, I'd like
to ask a favor of you.
>> Leonard Slatkin: Sure.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: And
that is to share with us
and our viewers a piece of
advice for how musicians
and people in the
cultural sector,
how we can use our position
as public figures with art
to motivate community
engagement?
>> Leonard Slatkin: You have
asked basically the question
of our time.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Yes.
>> Leonard Slatkin: And my
response to that is one,
always remember as an artist,
whatever kind of artist you are,
why you decided to
enter this profession.
What drove you?
Maybe it was a person in your
life who led you on this path.
Maybe you saw or heard
something that inspired you.
If you don't keep that in
the forefront of your mind,
you're just doing a job.
To be an artist is a very
special honor not many people
get to do it.
And so, conveying the passion
and the love for what you do,
that alone should be enough
to help inspire others.
The most noble part of what all
of us do is not what takes place
in the museum, in
the concert hall,
it's what takes place
in the classroom.
A big change in our society has
to do with the lack of education
that exists in the arts, but
also has to do with the change
for those people who
are people of faith.
Music has become quite secondary
in church services, synagogues,
mosques it's not thought of as
being the inspirational part
of what going to worship is,
and if you're an agnostic
or an atheist and you've decided
that you don't believe in any
of that, although I'm Jewish
by heritage and birth,
I'm not what one calls
devout or practicing.
I'm just not.
And the reason I'm not, is
because I get to do something
that people would
love to be able to do.
I take these circles
and these dots
and those little
instructions left to us,
they're sitting there
on a piece of paper
and I have these
musicians in front me
and I'm bringing
those ideas to life.
I'm doing what doctors
would love to do.
I can resurrect them, sometimes
successfully, sometimes not,
but I can that and if everybody
in our profession would
take more seriously
that this is not just a job,
but it's a real privilege
and a responsibility to pass
it on; conveying that love,
conveying that passion.
That's what's going to spread
out into the community.
Make sure people know about
what you do, who you are,
get in touch with marketing
people, with PR people,
whenever you can explain even
controversial art is a positive
because it's something created
that never existed before.
We really wish more
people could do that.
You're a young person now; what
happened between my generation
and today's young generation?
We became a more
visual-oriented society;
pop singer makes a
song, create the video.
Kids are driving or doing
whatever they do listening
in their things, song comes on,
are they really into the song
or are they flashing
to how it looked?
Which is usually a
director's vision of the song,
not necessarily the
artist who created it.
I want to get us back
to the time when all
of us had the power
of imagination,
as some people would put it,
be able to live your dreams,
and if we can do that as
a society, in conjunction
with physical responsibility,
with an aim towards things not
going towards the violent end
that they seem to go to sadly
these days, but understand
that bringing the
beauty of imagination
to the general public
I think we would all be
in a much better place.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: Well,
you've left me hopeful.
Thank you for sharing
those insights.
>> Leonard Slatkin: My pleasure.
>> Nicholas A. Brown: And
spending this time with us.
You can learn about the Library
of Congress's Preforming
Arts Resources at loc.gov
and please join us on
our YouTube Channel,
youtube.com/libraryofcongress,
excuse me,
youtube.com/librarycongress
for a series of interviews
with leading American
conductors.
Thanks and have a great day.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.